[Music]
It's getting to that time of year where
many of us start thinking about planting
our gardens. A main stay in most Wyoming
gardens would be the tomato plant. The
tomato plant is a great plant. When
selecting the tomato plant, we want to
look for certain things. We want to pick
a plant with overall health. We want to
look for any broken branches. We
especially want to look for plants that
are growing straight and uh and don't
have any discoloration on the leaves,
any signs of disease or any insects on
them. When we select the plant, most of
the tags will tell us how many days it
is to maturity. We want to certainly
select a plant that will work in our
where we live and in in our zone. When
we transplant the tomato plant, we can
gently take the tomato plant out,
remembering that we can pluck the bottom
branches off and actually plant the
plant deeper than than where it is in
the pot. Many people like to select
plants with uh blossoms on them and
maybe even some tomatoes. Uh remember,
with tomato plants, size doesn't
necessarily matter. The more blossoms
and the more tomatoes there are on the
plant, the more transplanting stress the
plant's going to go through. A big red
tomato is a great addition to any
kitchen table and I hope many of you
have lots this year. This is Hudson
Hill, University of Arming Extension and
you're watching From the Ground Up.
[Music]